The red thing is, think about my hand
is qiang ying.
To confuse someone, if I do like this,
even do faster, you probably get confused.
And then stab at you.
Hello everyone, I'm Zak Song.
I'm a professional kung
fu wushu martial artist.
I have been training and
teaching kung fu for 26 years.
Today we're gonna look at a
movie spear and staff fight
to see how realistic they are.
That's very realistic.
Staff is the fundamental training
for any kind long weapons
training, including spear.
You have to go through
the staff training first,
and then when you learn, spear
it will become much easier.
We do have a training, it's called a swap.
For example, my staff is here,
you trying to grab my staff.
But I will swap it.
You grab what? You grab empty.
And then I can use the
back to strike at you.
So that is very realistic as well.
That's a realistic sweep staff.
Staff is like for the range, for like say:
One, two, three, four...
Many people here, I can use the staff,
(Zak whooshing) hit like
that, that's a sweep.
But once you done a sweep,
you can (Zak whooshing) sweep,
like I mentioned before,
you have to use this energy to come back.
You don't want to (Zak
whooshing) let the staff
drag you away.
You use the energy (Zak
whooshing) and then come back.
That's very realistic as well.
The staff guy, he got a
hit, so he fly far away.
In kung fu we have another training,
it's called the ground techniques.
You have to know how to fall.
Someone trying to give you
a kick, you bam,
you jump in the air, you land.
You have to hold your
chi, which is energy.
If you don't hold your energy,
you land on the ground,
you'll be like, bam, the
energy goes like this.
You'll be like, oh, that's too painful.
All of the staff technique,
you can do it in real
life, it's no problem.
Nine, give him nine.
That's very good
choreography, very advanced.
Spear is one of the challenging weapon.
It's like a dragon.
Dragon is flexible, soft,
and at the same time, with power as well.
If I'm holding a spear, I
try to strike to this way.
And then I come back,
so I can bounce back.
So that's why the flexibility
is very important.
So if the spear is not flexible,
will be not that easy to bounce back.
If you are very good with kung fu,
you can do like this, no problem at all.
I'm holding a spear.
This is go like, which is block.
Someone trying to stab me with the sword,
I block, I take control, and then I stab.
In the situation you don't
know what's gonna happen.
If someone uses sword,
try to chop at your head,
the circle, still do the same, but bigger.
Then block and then
take control, and step.
You can move around.
For the martial art, for kung
fu, you can do that move.
Even in the real situation
you can do the chop like that.
That's no problem.
Any kind of weapon, you break
it, it's normally very common.
The spear we use, even the wooden one,
they made by white wax
wood, it's very flexible.
But like a plant, you have to water it,
it will become dry out which means
there's no juice left inside.
It will be very difficult to bounce.
You wanna bounce back, so you
have to do the maintenance.
Use too much power, it
will just pop, break.
"Crouching Tiger, Hidden Dragon," 10.
This staff is different from normal staff.
Normal staff, it just
depends on your own height.
The staff should be like,
with your own height
or five fingers taller.
See this staff is longer,
it's more challenge.
If I hold it like a normal staff
I can swap the staff easily,
I can strike with the back.
But the long weapon is very difficult.
If you swap back, it's gonna be challenge.
Long weapon is a big challenge.
You can see the moves, he
has used a lot of sweep.
You can see, he sweeps the legs.
That's very good choreography.
Also the style is very flexible.
He uses the flexibility to bounce back
to hit another opponent.
He does this, the circle like spear.
He can make some spear moves as well.
It's like you combine everything together.
Two versus one is very common,
so we do this kind of training.
Once you're good at one
versus one, two versus one.
And then you can one versus
many, depends on you.
If you good at it you can do like that.
That's no problem.
The move's very realistic,
you have the same per them.
Long weapon is a big challenge.
If this person get into
you, very close to you,
you have to think about it
because you hold a long weapons.
If I hold it like a normal staff
I can swap the staff easily,
I can strike with the back.
But the long weapon is very difficult.
You have maybe, hold the thing,
then trying to push this person back.
Every weapon, there's a break point.
Break point means the
energy release point.
Normally on the top, or in the end.
Sometimes you use the middle.
Energy point, you can see
the strikes, he always strike
with the top of his staff,
that's the energy point.
So the people, they
trying to get in closer
which means trying to
avoid the break point,
the energy point.
It isn't realistic in the
combat, but in the movie
they want to make it look cool to have the
exaggerate the moves.
They do have some pressure points.
He use this energy to bounce back to hit.
If you hit here with the power,
you do get someone knocked over.
And you just knock over.
Give this move a 10 as well.
The movement is good, two versus one.
The one person is using staff technique.
You can turn back, even
my opponent in the back,
you can feel behind.
I focus here, I know someone maybe use,
this side you can see in the back,
you hold your staff in the back.
And then because hold it back,
someone trying to strike at
me, my staff will block it.
I can use it to come back to strike.
You have to be very versatile
and flexible in a real combat.
There's no specific rules or steps.
The move is very realistic
because in combat
you don't need to do fancy
moves if you don't want,
unless you're very good at it.
You do the moves, like jump
higher, sweep your staff.
Because I think he is
using the light saber
at the ends, so that's why
he holds in the center.
He uses two sides as
break point to strike.
That's good.
He spin his staff as well.
It's all like a fundamental
staff basic training
and it's very good.
That's not real and
sometimes in a real combat
you can spin one circle
to use to swap your hands.
Spin one circle to use
it to swap your hand.
That's okay.
Let's say your opponent here,
you do a spinning strike
there, you can kick here.
You can be flexible, but too many times
that's like choreography.
The movies, to make it like cool.
You can see the moves is not coordinated,
you can tell straight
away, not coordinate at all
because there's no energy
come from the strike.
Once you're good at the kung fu, right?
You just naturally do it.
The moves for the staff
person, use is very realistic.
But just the spinning part,
okay it's very realistic
as well, but don't spin two circles.
You don't do like this,
it's just not cool.
I will say, give a seven.
That's wonderful.
Jet Li uses a lot of moves.
The block, that's a
basic move for the spear.
Block, control, and step.
If I'm hold a spear, I
look at the opportunities.
I watch carefully the opponent.
If he make a strike, a sword coming,
not here yet, you can block.
And then you do the next, you react to it,
you do the next move.
If you're good at that, you can use that.
Talk about the flips,
if you know how to flow
with the energy, it's not
tiring, you not get injured.
Unless you do more, over and over, over,
of course you get tired.
For some people they
don't know how to do it.
They do one, they'll be like exhausted.
I love all of his moves
because he's very good,
he's very flow.
That's wushu, he trained wushu as well.
You can see wushu is
more like flexible flow,
and also break points, and fast as well.
And in kung fu we see not just physical,
it's the spirit as well.
In kung fu we say,
(speaking foreign language)
"Together, coming together as one."
You hold your staff, or you hold a spear.
Together, the movement
will be different, alive.
That's very good, very good.
So the Mandarin for
spirit is called "qiang."
The red thing is, think
about my hand is qiang ying.
That one is for traditionally,
if I do like this,
do a circle to confuse someone.
If I do like this, even do faster,
you probably get confused,
and then stab you.
You don't know.
I try to confuse you and be
behind, strike like that.
So that's like a normal spear height,
but it is longer than the staff.
But in real situation that is possible.
If some people use the staff
to sweep at you, or spear,
they are the same.
If you use too much
power you hit your leg.
You can do like that if you hit very hard.
Our rating for this will be 10.
See, Jet Li's moves is
just flow, very advanced.
In kung fu wushu training we do have this.
See, from this height
I can spin one round,
swap to this height,
and do a posture like this.
If you are really good at kung fu
you can do any kind of pose.
You can control the situation.
You can start like this,
look at your opponent.
You can go pow, pow, you look back.
You feel the move, pow, pow.
It's not kung fu wushu
training, you can tell.
Kung fu martial art will require flow
and smooth coordination,
flexibility, everything together.
The footwork, is need to be light.
You can see the differences right?
You already see.
So when you do the moves,
such as the beginning,
the sword move this man doing at first.
Some modern-day actor and actress,
they can learn the moves.
But they cannot learn the internal part
which is the feeling, the spirit inside.
- One, zero.
- One, one.
- That's very important, the training.
You have to know how
to control your power.
In the sparring training,
even though we punch,
I can use full energy but I control
to not let my training
partner to get hurt.
I can go this, I know here to stop.
I don't go past that break point.
The break point, I say break
point, energy release point.
They don't go pow, they go past.
Your opponent will get injured.
The moves is very
practical, very realistic.
Even though they are using staff,
they're using sword technique.
When they're holding staff,
think about my arm is a staff,
but this move, this move, right?
This move, pow, pow, pow, hold the staff,
is a sword technique,
like a fundamental move
to make sure your wrist become flexible.
You can use it as chop
and then do like this.
Also combine some staff technique as well,
such as a sweep.
And this is chop, a sword chop.
The combat choreography, very practical.
The combat, the camera
moving always make me
little bit dizzy to watch.
That's an eight.
I like this one, this is like
a more traditional style.
There's a modern style, traditional style.
So traditional style
is more like practical.
If you go to a battle field, right?
The sword coming, I can just block.
Very straightforward
block, come back, and step.
A traditional style doesn't
do too much fancy moves,
it's just practical.
That's very realistic.
In a combat, you really
need to do like that.
Try and see like you know, part his spear,
he can come at you, kicks.
Come at your flying kicks together, right?
Kung fu is a holistic training.
If you want to master one thing
you have to holistic training.
You have to do the kicks training,
you have to the stances training.
You can see the spear, they
have extensive training.
They have basic stances you have to know.
And then there's basic kicks.
You have to know basic flying kicks.
Now you have to separate every single move
to come by other moves together
to be able do good at that.
You feel like you are
moving with him together.
You can see his body language, everything.
That's very good.
That's very realistic and also advanced.
Our rating for this will be 10.
My favorite one is like, Jet
Li's one, the "Fearless" one.
The reason is I do the same
style as Jet Li, wushu.
I enjoy the moves as a flow
and also smooth choreography,
everything together
and make it like real as well.
If you enjoy the video, please
click the above for another.